passing lanes one-on-one defending  incredible defender with tremendous  hands you know the warriors are glad to  have him back brown  and get you big-time buckets one-on-one  on attack oh williams caught a body  underneath  and here comes boston  white  brown  man he's cooking  jalen brown with 22 in the ball game  exactly what i'm talking about you  double team  curry gives up himself iguodala makes  the leave  pritchard from the corner  white  good close out by curry it didn't matter  derek white white on the drive  back to horford for the lead  boston up by  swing the basketball  all the ladies in the house say ow  working against wigan  got the smart in rhythm for three splash  what a flurry  by boston 21 of 41  from three-point territory  that is  incredibly insane  and inordinate  the celtics take game one